re bonjour à tous je prends donc ma
deuxième casquette effectivement sur la
question de la salle de shoot puisque
vous savez que la gauche a lancé depuis
quelques années un projet
d'expérimentation de salles de shoot
la première expérimentation aura lieu
dans le 10e arrondissement
le lieu d'implantation était auparavant
prévu au 39 boulevard de la chapelle et
depuis quelques mois le projet sera
finalement intégrée au sein de l'hôpital
lariboisière
moi je vais essayer de revenir assez
rapidement sur les raisons qui
aujourd'hui font que nous nous opposons
avec frédéric et avec philippe puisque
je je mène évidemment ce ce combat avec
eux deux depuis plusieurs années les
raisons qui font qu'on s'oppose à la
salle de shoot
tout d'abord j'aimerais vraiment
rappeler parce que c'est un point auquel
moi je tiens beaucoup que la salle de
shoot ce n'est évidemment pas une
solution pour les toxicomanes
on n'osera pas on ne tendra pas la main
aux toxicomanes en ouvrant une salle de
shoot la salle de shoot n'est pas fait
pour ce vrai elle n'est pas faite pour
soigner ou pour aider
elle est faite pour enfermer les
toxicomanes dans leur addiction
donc moi c'est évidemment quelque chose
que je ne peux pas soutenir et une
attitude que je considère totalement
irresponsable de la part des pouvoirs
publics
pour bien comprendre cet argument il
faut se projeter un petit peu sur la
manière dont les choses vont se passer
quand vous allez avoir un toxicomane qui
rentrera dans la salle de shoot
vous aurez beau avoir au sein de cette
salle tout le personnel médical social
tout ce que vous voulez les plus grands
spécialistes de delà de la place à
partir du moment où le toxicomane
arrivera il ne sera évidemment pas en
état puisqu'il sera en manque
ce qui vient se faire une injection
c'est qu'il est en manque donc il ne
sera évidemment pas en état de se voir
prodiguer quelques conseils que ce soit
le deuxième argument est là dessus on
contre un peu les socialistes qui
s'appuie toujours sur cet élément les
socialistes nous sortent toujours les
éléments les exemples pardon étrangers
la france en la matière serait
rétrograde au ray
un train de retard puisque on n'aurait
pas encore ouvert notre salle de shoot
alors oui effectivement il ya certains
de nos voisins notamment de nos voisins
européens qui ont ouvert des salles de
shoot
mais ce qu'ils oublient souvent de dire
c'est que nombre d'entre eux les ont
fermé ensuite ces cas par exemple de la
suède où effectivement des salles de
shoot avait été ouverte avait été
expérimentée et en raison de résultats
qualifiés de peu convaincant par les
autorités les salles ont été fermés il
oublie également d'indiquer que par
exemple en allemagne à partir du moment
où les salles de shoot ont été ouvertes
on a enregistré + cats 15% toxicomanes
en allemagne c'est quand même ça ne
tient évidemment pas la route c'est un
argument qui ne peut pas être recevable
et troisième élément c'est un élément
plus locale la manière dont les choses
se passent à paris concernant la salle
de shoot est assez symptomatique
finalement des méthodes utilisées par
les socialistes à paris le madame
hidalgo et son équipe a pris pour
habitude de consulter les parisiens sur
des projets qui finalement ont très peu
d'impact sur la vie quotidienne et le la
vie concrète des parisiens alors en
revanche quand il s'agit d'un projet
d'envergure qui aura véritablement une
implication et des conséquences sur la
vie la vie de tout un chacun
là évidemment on ne consulte pas on
prépare le projet en catimini et c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé sur la
salle de shoot pour laquelle il n'y a eu
aucune concertation digne de ce nom
je vais d'ailleurs vous raconter une
petite anecdote à ce sujet dans le xème
évidemment vous imaginez que la
situation est un petit peu tendu dans le
quartier de la gare du nord avec avec ce
projet puisque c'est déjà un quartier
qui qui concentrent beaucoup de
problèmes de sécurité
donc évidemment des collectifs de
riverains des associations se sont
constituées et on a organisé tout temps
tous ensemble un certain nombre de
manifestations est aujourd'hui la
situation est aussi tendue que lors du
dernier conseil de quartier ou le
conseil de quartier avaient voulu au
mois de juin que le maire présente enfin
le projet ce qu'ils n'avaient pas encore
fait le conseil de quartier a mis le
projet de salles de shoot à son ordre du
jour et le maire n'est pas venu
j'appelle ça un mois une politique pas
très courageuse et en tout cas une
attitude pas très courageux donc
évidemment
qu'est ce que nous on propose en face
puisque il faut pas le nier il ya une
question autour lacoste toxicomanie à
paris notamment dans le quartier de la
gare du nord donc est ce qu'on propose
aujourd'hui les choses sont assez
simples
d'une part il faut évidemment renforcer
la politique sanitaire et le volet
préventif qui marche plutôt bien à paris
il faut savoir par exemple que notamment
sur l'initiative de philippe goujon il
ya il ya quelques années des seringues
ont été mises des seringues propres ont
été mises en service dans des
distributeurs autour de la gare du nord
aujourd'hui ce sont 150 mille seringue
parents qui sont distribués donc la
politique sanitaire fonctionne
deuxième volet c'est évidemment de
tendre la main aux toxicomanes de
manière à les aider à sortir de leur
dépendance est évidemment allé à les
aider à se réintégrer dans la société
donc là aussi on a des choses qui marche
plutôt pas mal aujourd'hui qu'il faut
sur lesquels il faudrait mettre l'accent
je pense notamment aux communautés
thérapeutiques auquel moi je crois
beaucoup qui permettent à la fois une
prise en charge sociale et médicale du
toxicomane
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire sur le
sujet aujourd'hui je suis évidemment
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions